[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis guten Abend schön dass Sie
dabei sind was im Sport passiert ist das
erfahren Sie von Norbert Lehmann
die Welt schaut auf die Russland
ukraine-krise
wie geht es weiter in der Ostukraine es
gibt Truppenbewegungen und Gefechte aber
russlands Präsident Putin hält sich mit
seinen Plänen bedeckt
ein Land im alarmmodus die Regierung der
Ukraine mobilisiert Reservisten und will
den Ausnahmezustand verhängen
und deutliches Plus bei Mindestlohn die
Bundesregierung beschließt ein Anstieg
auf 12 Euro ab Oktober
was hat Putin genau vor darüber wird
weiter gerätselt um sich zu schützen
rüstet sich die Ukraine für einen Krieg
die EU will in diesen Stunden Sanktionen
in Kraft treten lassen wir schauen
gleich darauf zuerst aber blicken wir
nach Russland selbst da war heute
Feiertag zu Ehren des Militärs und da
spielte auch eine Rolle das Russland die
ostukrainischen Regionen Don jetzt und
luhansk als unabhängig anerkannt hat
Christian sem berichtet
Schüsse an der Frontlinie in der
Ostukraine die Waffenruhe wird hier
wieder und wiedergebrochen gegenseitige
Schuldzuweisungen
jetzt kann man es deutlich hören wie
unsere Nachbarn beschossen werden und
wir hören wie Zivilisten beschossen
werden
während sie im Donbass schießen wird in
Russland dem russischen Militär
geholtigt auch mit kleinen Paraden der
Tag des vaterlandsverteidigers ein
wichtiger nationaler Feiertag in einer
brisanten Zeit das Vaterland im Herzen
die Spielzeugwaffe in der Handtasche der
Panzer wird zum Spielplatz mit dem
Militär kommt man hier schon sehr früh
in Berührung
man muss sich von Kindheit an dran
gewöhnen ein Mann soll sich selbst sein
Vaterland und seine Liebsten verteidigen
können
natürlich haben wir Angst vor Krieg
Krieg ist schrecklich deshalb braucht
man solche Paraden damit die junge
Generation eine Vorstellung davon
bekommt warum das schlecht ist
Präsident Putin legte zum Feiertag einen
Kranz nieder am Grab des unbekannten
Soldaten an der Kremlmauer und Putin
sagt Russland sei immer offen für einen
direkten und ehrlichen Dialog aber
die Interessen Russlands die Sicherheit
unserer Bürger sind für uns
bedingungslos deshalb werden wir uns
weiterentwickeln und Armee und Marine
verbessern um sicherzustellen dass Ihre
Effizienz steigt damit sie mit der
neuesten Technologie ausgestattet sind
in den rebellengebieten sieht man
Militärfahrzeuge ohne offizielle
Hoheitsabzeichen wie damals 2014 als
Russland die Krim annektierte ob sie zum
russischen Militär gehören unklar
separatistenführer puschillin bestreitet
die russische Präsenz
im Moment gibt es hier keine russischen
Truppen und vor diesen Ereignissen haben
alle internationalen Beobachter
einschließlich der OSZE hier nach ihnen
gesucht aber sie haben Sie nicht
gefunden
was die Zukunft betrifft ob es möglich
ist das russische Truppen hier sind es
ist möglich
ein Vertreter der kreml-partei lässt in
Don jetzt heute wissen man werde nur in
die Separatisten Gebiete einmarschieren
wenn man darum gebeten werde
Christian sem es ist also nicht klar ob
russische Truppen bereits in den
Separatisten Gebieten sind oder nicht
was soll dieses verwirr Spiel Moskau
begann gestern schon da war ja zunächst
unklar Putin tatsächlich den Einsatz
Befehl dazu gegeben hat das ganze ging
dann hier durch die Institution und da
könnte das tatsächlich machen und dieses
verwirr Spiel das gehört natürlich zur
Taktik das Putin Ding am ungefähren
lässt dass man nicht genau weiß was
passiert das oder passiert das nicht
einer der separatistenführer hat ja auch
gesagt russische Truppen könnten
jederzeit kommen wenn nötig und das kann
man als Warnung verstehen an die Ukraine
nach dem Motto wenn ihr uns angreift
dann hilft uns der große Bruder und dann
könnte es natürlich brenzlig werden weil
dann könnten sich ukrainische Truppen
und russische Truppen an der Frontlinie
direkt gegenüberstehen was wir sehen
sind militärische Aktivitäten im Süden
Russlands wir haben da unser Team hat
das selbstbeobachtet konvoice gesehen
die Richtung
Separatisten Gebiete fahren und das
passiert auf russischem Boden ob sie
dann da ankommen und wann ist derzeit
unklar danke das schon mal für diese
Einordnung Christian sem
angesichts der Bedrohung bereitet sich
die Ukraine auf einen russischen
Einmarsch vor so soll landesweite
Ausnahmezustand eingeführt werden
zunächst für 30 Tage dadurch könnten
unter anderem Ausgangssperren verhängt
werden zudem wurde mit der Einberufung
von Reservisten begonnen Präsident
selenski forderte von Russland
Sicherheitsgarantien und bekam heute in
Kiew solidaritätsbesuch aus der EU
Lothar Becker berichtet
der polnische Präsident duda und sein
litauischer Amtskollege nauseda zeigen
heute Geschlossenheit mit der Ukraine
unterstützen einen möglichen Status als
EU-Beitrittskandidat nicht zuletzt heißt
es aufgrund der angespannten
Sicherheitslage
wir verteidigen uns selbst mit der Hilfe
unserer Partner aber wir die Ukrainer
sind es die sterben werden die Ukraine
braucht Sicherheitsgarantien klar
konkret und jetzt weil wir sicher sein
wollen dass wir die Menschen und unsere
Häuser beschützen können
währenddessen bereiten sich die Menschen
auch hier in Lemberg ganz im Westen der
Ukraine auf den nationalen Notstand und
die Einberufung von Reservisten vor
aber ich werde wohl so schnell nicht
eingezogen weil ich erstmal wieder ein
Training brauche meine Ausbildung ist
schon lange her und ich bin keine 20 30
und auch keine 40 Jahre mehr
ich versuche heute schon den ganzen Tag
alle Unterlagen für eine
Waffenbesitzkarte zu bekommen
an der Akademie für Lebensrettung in
Lemberg werden derzeit nicht nur
Sanitäter und Rettungskräfte ausgebildet
seit Wochen gibt es hier öffentliche
Erste-Hilfe-Kurse auch für Schulklassen
die Teilnehmenden lernen außerdem wie
Sie sich im Krisenfall verhalten sollen
auch hier in Lemberg wo wir relativ weit
weg sind von der Situation im Osten
liegt eine gewisse Anspannung in der
Luft wir wissen nicht wie sich Putin
entscheiden wird es ist schade dass das
Schicksal so vieler Menschen von den
Entscheidungen eines so inkompetenten
Führers abhängt
russland hat sein diplomatisches
Personal inzwischen aus der Ukraine
abgezogen auch das Generalkonsulat in
Lemberg wurde geräumt
Axel Storm in Kiew jetzt Bericht über
Cyberangriffe auf die Ukraine was ist
dazu bekannt
genau am frühen Nachmittag hat der
ukrainische digitalminister Arm
geschlagen es gäbe große Angriffe auf
webserver-infrastruktur auf
Internetseiten der Regierung das
Parlament des betroffen gewesen der die
Website des Premierministers und des
Präsidenten und was aber viel wichtiger
ist ist dass das digitale Bürgerportal
die ja in dem 10.000 100.000 von
Menschen ihre persönlichen Daten ihre
Pässe ihre Studentenausweise ihre
QR-Codes gespeichert haben wohl auch
angegriffen worden ist es ist im Moment
noch nicht bekannt wie viele Daten da
verloren gegangen sind ob überhaupt
Daten verloren gegangen worden gegangen
sind aber es ist natürlich so ein Moment
in dem man sagt okay es wird vielleicht
jetzt langsam ernst und während all das
passiert ist hat wir haben das eben ein
Stück gesehen Russland seinen
diplomatisches Personal aus allen
Standorten in der Ukraine abgezogen
Dankeschön Axel storm
um Russland in die Schranken zu weisen
sollen heute die Sanktionen der EU
inkraft treten die eu-staats- und
regierungschefinnen und Chefs werden
zudem morgen zu einem Sondergipfel
zusammenkommen die Anwendung von Gewalt
und Zwang zur Veränderung von Grenzen
hat im 21 Jahrhundert keinen Platz
twittert dazu EU-Ratspräsident Michelle
Jürgen berichtet
Solidarität mit der Ukraine die
Botschaft dieser Demonstration zur
Stunde vor dem russischen Konsulat in
Hamburg kaum zu erwarten dass
öffentlicher Druck Putin zum Einlenken
bringt der westenhof da eher auf die
erste Stufe seiner Sanktionen eine
schwarze Liste für alle Banken die mit
den ostukrainischen Separatisten
zusammenarbeiten und das Aus für Putins
russische Staatsanleihen an wichtigen
westlichen Finanzplätzen
wir setzen ihn gemeinsam unter Druck
erklärt der britische Premier Johnson in
London Paris New York gleichzeitig
einträchtiges Handeln ist absolut
unerlässlich
außerdem die EU und Japan beschlossen
den Handel mit Unternehmen aus dem
Separatisten Gebiet zu beenden und in
Kraft sind auch Sanktionen gegen
hunderte politische Entscheidungsträgern
Moskau und gegen Geschäftsleute die
Putin stützen sie dürfen nicht mehr
einreisen und ihre Konten werden
eingefroren
die einzige Sanktionen dem für Russland
wichtigen Energiesektor Deutschland
eingeleitet
genehmigungsstopp für die Pipeline Nord
Stream 2 Russland drohte daraufhin
unverhohlen mit höheren Gaspreisen die
deutsche Außenministerin gibt sich
unbeeindruckt
für eine freie souveräne und
demokratische Ukraine nehmen wir
wirtschaftliche Folgen in Kauf Frieden
und Freiheit in Europa haben kein
Preisschild weitere Sanktionen seien
vorbereitet der Westen steht der Ukraine
zur Seite und hofft auf ein Einlenken
Russlands
ZDF heute live um 19.30 geht der Frage
nach was bringen Sanktionen und
ebenfalls in unserer ZDF heute-app
halten wir Sie über die neuen
Entwicklungen immer auf dem Laufenden
zum Beispiel mit unserem Live-Blog
der Konflikt kann also bei uns ein
bestehendes Problem weiter verschärfen
und zwar dass der Energiepreise seit
Anfang letzten Jahres steigen Sie immer
weiter an im Januar mussten
VerbraucherInnen gut 20,5% mehr für
Stromheizung und Kraftstoff bezahlen als
vor einem Jahr die Ampelkoalition will
daher die Haushalte entlasten wie genau
darum ging es bis eben im
Koalitionsausschuss
was ist dabei herausgekommen und die
Pressekonferenz ist wirklich vor fünf
Minuten beendet worden und wie erwartet
sollen die Verbraucher bei den
Stromkosten entlastet werden das heißt
die Ökostrom Umlage wird bereits zum
ersten Juli abgeschafft ursprünglich
sollte sie ja Anfang kommenden Jahres
wegfallen dank des vorziehens spart also
ein durchschnittlicher Haushalt rund 50
Euro dazu soll es eine steuerliche
Entlastung geben der sogenannte
Arbeitnehmer Pauschbetrag bei der
Einkommenssteuer der wird um 200 Euro
erhöht auf
1.200 außerdem wird der Steuer
Grundfreibetrag um 363 euro auf
insgesamt
10.347 Euro angehoben und die
fernpendlerpauschale wird rückwirkend ab
dem 1 Januar auf 38 Cent pro Kilometer
erhöht für Menschen die Existenz
sichernde Leistungen beziehen gibt es
einen einmaligen corona-zuschuss von 100
Euro und der schon im Koalitionsvertrag
vereinbarte sofort Zuschlag für von
Armut betroffene Kinder der wird zum
ersten Juli auf den Weg gebracht er soll
in Höhe von 20 Euro pro Monat denjenigen
Kindern helfen die besondere finanzielle
Unterstützung brauchen zusätzlich gibt
es kleine Entlastungen bei der Steuer
und des Kurzarbeitergeld wird verlängert
insgesamt zehn Maßnahmen im
zweistelligen Milliardenbereich danke
Theo call über die Vorhaben der
Ampelkoalition
zu Corona die Inzidenz in Deutschland
geht weiter zurück das
Robert-Koch-Institut registrierte
209.52 positive Tests innerhalb eines
Tages das sind 10.920 weniger als vor
einer Woche
299 Menschen starben im Zusammenhang mit
covid 19 bin eines Tages die sieben Tage
Inzidenz sinkt auf 1278,9
im Wahlkampf hatte sich Olaf Scholz
darauf festgelegt ein Mindestlohn von 12
Euro heute nun hat das Kabinett für die
Erhöhung grünes Licht gegeben der
Arbeitgeberverband BDA ist darüber alles
andere als begeistert und überlegt zu
klagen das Gesetz muss noch durch den
Bundestag damit der Bund Mindestlohn zum
1 Oktober auf 12 Euro steigen kann wenn
Benthin
für die Kameras geht der Arbeitsminister
heute zu denen die bald mehr Geld in der
Tasche haben 12 Euro Mindestlohn das war
Wahlkampfversprechen Nummer eins der SPD
heute bringt ihn die Ampelkoalition im
Kabinett auf den Weg Arbeit wird in
Deutschland gebraucht die muss anständig
bezahlt werden und wir reden ja über
Menschen die wirklich fleißig und hart
arbeiten wie in dieser Bäckerei
beispielsweise und die mehr verdient
haben seit der Einführung 2015 stieg der
Mindestlohn von 8,50 € auf derzeit 9,82
Euro im Juli soll er dann auf 10,45 Euro
und ab Oktober auf 12 Euro steigen eine
Anhebung die vom Bundestag beschlossen
wird die Arbeitgeber halten das für
juristisch fragwürdig als der
Mindestlohn eingeführt wurde hat die
Politik versprochen dass die
mindestlohnkommission den Mindestlohn
festlegt das hat sie bisher immer
einvernehmlich gemacht jetzt greift die
Politik ein und macht aus dem
Mindestlohn ein staatslohn das ist ein
schwerer ver Ausbruch die Gewerkschaften
halten dagegen der jetzige Eingriff sei
eine Art Notwehr gegen Lohndrückerei
einige Arbeitgeber Funktionäre arbeiten
mit Herzblut gegen den gesetzlichen
Mindestlohn vom ersten Tag an und auch
jetzt und dass sie versuchen dass jetzt
noch mal rechtlich sagen zu
sanktionieren ist ja nichts anderes als
der Versuch Armutslöhne zu verfestigen
und das ist absolut verwerflich über 6
Millionen Menschen sollen vom
Mindestlohn profitieren besonders stark
Beschäftigte in Ostdeutschland und
besonders stark Frauen
Bayerns Ministerpräsidentin CSU-Chef
Markus Söder besetzt Spitzenposten neuer
CSU-Generalsekretär wird der
Bundestagsabgeordnete und frühere
Innenstaatssekretär Stefan Mayer sein
Vorgänger Markus Blume wechselt ins
bayerische Kabinett Söder hofft auf
einen Schub für die Landtagswahl im
Herbst 2023
Engpässe bei Medikamenten auch in
Deutschland gehört das immer wieder zum
Alltag mit verantwortlich sind häufig
globale Lieferketten und der Kostendruck
bei Schmerzmitteln etwa oder Antibiotika
ganz aktuell ist das jetzt bei Tamoxifen
der Fall einem Mittel gegen Brustkrebs
das vor allem jüngere Patientinnen in
Deutschland täglich nehmen müssen Sandra
Susanka mit den Details
seit Wochen bekommt dr Kuhn verzweifelte
E-Mails von Brustkrebspatientinnen
Tamoxifen ein lebenswichtiges Medikament
ist kaum noch zu bekommen die gängigen
dreimonats-packungen sind bei vielen
fast aufgebraucht wir haben junge Frauen
ab 27 26 Jahre die Brustkrebs haben die
dringend dieses Medikament brauchen die
ihre Sterberate sinken wollen mit diesem
Medikament müssen wir sagen wir haben
momentan
kein kein Ersatzpräparat es betrifft
Frauen die noch nicht in den
Wechseljahren sind wie die 43-Jährige
Doris Heberle Tamoxifen hemmt das
Wachstum hormonabhängiger Tumorzellen
täglich nehmen es fast 130.000 Frauen
bis zu zehn Jahre lang
das ist ein altbewährtes Medikament und
gibt mir Sicherheit und Schutz die
Vorstellung dass dann aufgrund von einem
Medikament was nicht verfügbar ist da so
eine Unsicherheit kommt also das ist
total unvorstellbar das ist macht
natürlich in aller erster Linie Angst
die Gründe für den Versorgungsengpass
sind vielfältig die marktverdichtung
spielt eine Rolle nur noch drei
generische Hersteller bedienen den
Großteil des Marktes denkpass ist im
Wesentlichen jetzt entstanden weil ein
wichtiger Zulieferer oder mehrere
wichtige Zuliefer ausgefallen sind bzw
eben aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen sich
aus der Produktion zurückgezogen haben
inzwischen gibt es aber Hoffnung dass
Hersteller in Deutschland die nötigen
Wirkstoffe besorgen können und Tamoxifen
kurzfristig hier herstellen so der
pharma-verband damit deshalb Mitte des
Jahres wieder verfügbar ist
und wir beginnen jetzt in Sport mit
Tennis Star Alexander Zverev der hat
sich ja beim Turnieren Acapulco wirklich
vollkommen daneben benutzt ein totaler
Wutausbruch nach seiner Niederlage im
Doppel er schlug mehrfach mit dem
Schläger auf den schiedsrichterstuhl ein
die Folge Disqualifikation für das
gesamte Turnier auch fürs Einzel der
Titelverteidiger hat sich inzwischen für
sein Verhalten entschuldigt
einsichtlich unausgeschlafene Alexander
Zverev bringt sich immer mehr in Rage
ein Ball den er klar im ausgesehen hat
wird vom Referee gut gegeben das Doppel
mit seinem Partner Marcelo Melo aus
Brasilien wird zur Nervenschlacht den
Gegnern einem britisch-finischen Duo
gelingt kurz darauf der Sieg im
Tie-Break des dritten Satzes und dann
verliert zvere völlig die Beherrschung
auch wenn er sich noch so sehr um
Unrecht fühlen mag dieser Attacke gegen
den schiedsrichterstuhl mit samt
Unparteiischen ein indiskutabler
Ausraster seine Disqualifikation
folgerichtig der zertrümmerte Schläger
wird zum Fanartikel
zu den Achtelfinals in der Fußball
Champions League Villarreal und Juve
trennten sich eins zu eins und
Titelverteidiger Chelsea siegte 2:0
gegen Lidl gute Ausgangsposition fürs
Rückspiel Mitte März
zwei ehemalige Bundesligaspieler sind
die Entscheider beim glatten Sieg von
Chelsea an der stemfort Bridge die
ersten 8 Minuten gehören dabei fast ganz
allein Kai havertz zwei Mal Maß genommen
mit der dritten Chance dann getroffen
havertz der frühere Leverkusener bleibt
bei Chelsea der Mann für die wichtigen
Tore der französische Meister Lille ist
in vielen Phasen gleichwertig allerdings
machen die Londoner vor was Effektivität
bedeutet Christian puristic ehemaliger
Dortmunder zum 2:0 entstand nicht alles
hat geklappt bei Tuchels Chelsea aber
die Perspektive fürs Viertelfinale
stimmt
und die Achtelfinalspiele von gestern
und heute ausführlich zu sehen bei uns
im Sportstudio um 23 Uhr und schon ab 20
Uhr im Livestream auf Sportstudio de das
Frauenfußball Länderspiel England
Deutschland das letzte Spiel der DFB-Elf
beim Turnier in Ruhe vorhanden ist ein
echter Härtetest denn die Gastgeberin
die sind ein Titel Favorit bei ihrer
Heim EM im Juli
das war vom Sport danke Norbert und wir
machen weiter mit den Lottozahlen
schauen wir mal drauf die Gewinnzahlen
lauten 5 7 11 15 24 47 und die Superzahl
ist die 2 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
eine neue Kaltfront zieht auf und macht
das Wetter leider wieder ungemütlicher
mehr dazu gleich von östantali um 21 Uhr
begrüßt Sie Christian Sievers zum
heute-journal schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die nächste
Kaltfront erreicht uns morgen im
Tagesverlauf aber vorher wird milde Luft
herangeführt und so steigen die
Temperaturen im Süden Deutschlands bis
auf 15 Grad aber die Wärme wird schon
wieder abgedrängt mit dieser Kaltfront
dahinter kommen Schauer und übermorgen
sogar Gewitter wir schauen auf die
nachts da kommen schon viele Wolken auf
von der Nordsee frisch der Wind auf aus
Südwesten liegt in Richtung teils
stürmische Böden nach Südosten klares
auf und dort wird es eisig bis -5 Grad
hier die tiefsten Werte ganz im Westen
plus 7 Grad morgen dann im Tagesverlauf
allmählich weitere wolkenzunahme von
Nordwesten her zunächst ist es in den
frühschuhen noch trocken aber dann
beginnt es zu regnen am Nachmittag liegt
die Kaltfront quer über Deutschland im
Südosten ist es trocken und hier scheint
die Sonne dort die höchsten Temperaturen
bis 15 Grad
oberrain 14 in Schleswig-Holstein sieben
Grad die kommenden Tage Rechte
unbeständig dann am Freitag mit Schauern
und die besagten Gewittern bei vier bis
zehn Grad das Wochenende wird zu etwas
kühler sein aber dafür auch sonniger
damit ein schöner Abend